joining me now is missouri senator josh
hawley of the judiciary committee
senator thanks for being with us tonight
now the left tried to
wish away
the issue of crt in our schools in
virginia
and it seems to be
the same case here they're kind of
wishing this away like oh this is all
exaggerated this isn't really a problem
it's it's all you know on the up and up
but
doesn't it seem like they're kind of
defending the indefensible but they
won't turn back
absolutely i mean listen this is now the
official line from the white house and
the senate democrats
that child pornography and child
exploitation is apparently all just a
conspiracy theory it's just in people's
heads it's just in the heads of
conservatives it's absolutely
outrageously false and you're exactly
right laura these are the same people
who said that if you have concern about
what your children are being taught
you're a domestic terrorist so i don't
think that sat very well with voters
this last november based on the election
returns and i would just say that voters
this november going to have a similar
choice do you want a party that is soft
on crime and a president who nominates
supreme court justices who give child
pornographers and child exploiters a
slap on the wrist or do you want to get
serious about it and protect your
children that's going to be the choice
yeah this is why we're giving parents an
opportunity to share their stories about
what they're seeing in their schools
even if they're afraid to say it at a
school board meeting
they're going to be able to tell us and
that's why we set up you know our our
big pool of information that we launched
tonight now to your point senator uh
this disturbing exchange between
congresswoman lauren beaubert and hhs
secretary becerra today watch
do you believe that a child is capable
of making
life-altering
decisions to maim themselves
so let me let me just say to you that i
don't agree with your premise
but what i will say to you is children
know much about themselves i believe in
supporting and protecting transgender
youth and i would really urge that
politicians like you stay out of their
business
now senator
this is supporting child abuse
so
will will you call for his rem immediate
removal just for that line
yeah absolutely and i think this idea
that parents should be told by
bureaucrats how to raise their children
that parents should be told that the
government knows best and it can dictate
to them what is best for their children
i mean this is really a decision that
parents need to make parents know what's
best for their children not these
government bureaucrats and to hear these
people who are pushing this agenda say
to parents you know you ought to step
back you ought to stay out of it you
ought to be quiet i just think it's
crazy
yeah as a mother i'm i'm watching this
entire debate unfold and i keep saying
to myself
is this really america is this really
where we are in the country where it's
debate about whether a five-year-old
should be taught the intricacies of
gender identity
and by the way to this point that you
were alluding to earlier
everyone has to hear this exchange this
was dick durbin responding yesterday
to your legislation that would toughen
sentences for child porn offenders watch
i have to ask myself
why now
why does the junior senator from
missouri bring this bill to the floor of
the united states senate today these
guidelines that you promulgated don't
reflect the reality of today we now live
in a world of internet
and access to not just tens and hundreds
but thousands of images if that is your
decision
does doesn't that make it actually more
pressing
that this legislation actually be taken
up and voted on i mean that it's easy
it's more accessible now so kids can get
exploited more easily
more frequently because of the internet
and durban's like well
just change now things are different
you know first of all only soft on crime
liberals have to ask about why you would
need to protect children now i mean no
parent in america ask that they know why
it's because child exploitation is
rampant it's because child pornography
is rampant it's because our children are
more vulnerable than ever before you
should never have to ask why but the
reason is we have a crisis on our hands
and by the way the judge jackson
hearings for the supreme court have only
made clear just how significant the
problem of child exploitation and child
pornography really is so yeah congress
should act they should have acted a long
time ago but they should act now and
this is the time to get tough on child
pornographers this is the time to get
tough on those who abuse children that's
why i say the choice is going to be
clear in november people can either have
a party that is soft on crime and soft
on people who exploit child child
offenders who are child offenders
exploit children or you can choose
somebody in the republicans i hope who
say listen we'll protect your children
senator hawley thank you for leading on
this issue we're going to have an
important follow-on to this story
tomorrow night thank you senator
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else